[Music]
where does the media fall into this
equation because I both the mainstream
media I mean I get when when Trump talks
about fake news now again I know I don't
know what his moral center is the guy
obviously lies left and right right so I
put that out there at the same time I do
get the fake news thing I see the way
all of the news spins everything
constantly that almost everyone now is a
partisan hack it's almost impossible to
get anything else where does the media
fall in in the free speech conversation
because it's like we need some
mainstream media that we trust because
it can't all be reliant on online media
because there's a lot of garbage here to
try no people can say whatever they want
about me that's fine I'll defend their
right to say it but where does that fall
into the conversation having a strong
media and a Fourth Estate
I mean I I think it I think it is an
absolute must have
I don't I don't think you can have a
functioning democracy without it and I
think that there is enough diversity I
think that the danger right now is is
the what people are calling the siloing
of it and you you are able now just to
get the media that reinforces your
already held beliefs in your
preconceived notions you don't there is
no requirement in any of these other
these outlets to hear a genuine opposing
point of view you get to your talking
points and you know kind of lip service
oftentimes I was one of the reasons I
liked your show and like listening to it
you get you get to hear opposing points
of view without without the shouting and
the quick I could so it's it's and to me
it's it's a little and it's also
actually I think I have a little bit of
a different perspective on this too
because the work that we do at FFRF is
historically very very unpopular and so
I interact with the media I mean I I do
probably maybe three or four hundred
interviews every year you know we do it
or the legal team not not myself yeah
and what you say to the media and what
is actually happening the genuine facts
on the ground versus what gets reported
are the distance between them can be so
great and it can even
be really great when you're talking
about you know the nons nonpartisan
groups not just fox news when fox news
is just insane when you're looking at
what is actually having an in FFRF case
and what is reported on fox news is
right it's night and day but even some
of the local stations do they bring some
of your guys on there they've actually
kind of kind of stopped doing that
really yeah because we've I think
because we've been effective my first
interview ever on any TV was Bill
O'Reilly
I sat down with him to talk about
Obama's second inauguration and whether
or not taking an oath on the Bible and
saying so help me God after the oath of
office should be he should do that my
stance was he shouldn't do that because
the Constitution lays out the
presidential oath very clearly and it
doesn't include the word so help me God
yeah how about put your hand on the
Constitution you think that we're
actually governed by all agree is the
thing we're governed by precisely and
that's what I was arguing for and it was
it was completely bizarre experience too
because I had a earbud in and Bill
O'Reilly just talking into my brain and
I'm just looking into a camera very
disconcerting yeah even that little
thing for people that no no this is a
little insider baseball when you do
those satellite shows you're sometimes
there's a little delay on the video so
it's even hard to match that up and
that's why those conversations are very
stilted at times and you know obviously
he's a seasoned pro who's gonna get his
points across and they've done a
pre-interview with you and all that we
don't do a pre-interview here I talk to
you for 30 seconds before and it's nice
it's nice to be able to see the your and
you're absolutely right and that was how
it went down with Bill O'Reilly and his
whole shtick is to interrupt you anyway
before you can get your point out and
with that little bit of a delay it made
it even worse he did tell me that I was
gonna be going to heaven and that I
could have a conversation with George
Washington and Martin Luther King when I
got there so you know it's funny I would
probably get some [ __ ] for saying this
but I think generally he's one of the
more moderate people at this point on
cable news I think he actually does try
to talk to people from both sides now he
may not be perfect and I've been on
there he compared something I said to
Hitler so you know it's all it's all
relative okay so when you said that to
him the idea of why wouldn't you put
your hand on the Constitution the thing
we're governed by what's the comeback to
that like I genuinely have never
understood a cogent comeback to that
I mean I mean I don't I don't think
there is
one right there I mean it the the
argument always goes to tradition and
it's the idea well George Washington he
put his hand on a Bible and he said so
help me God
he didn't say so help me God I actually
got Bill O'Reilly to admit that on the
air I felt like that was that was very
good and any argument from tradition is
just to me is immediately suspect and I
think it should be throw if you can't
come up with a good reason now to be
doing something other than it's been
done for 200 years I don't want to hear
that I think that I think that's a
terrible argument and it's especially
terrible when you're talking about
courts deciding cases but it's something
that comes up in in my line of work all
the time that's very very frustrating I
mean the tradition argument not only
just doesn't make sense because it's not
what we're governed by but a lot of the
people that would argue for that are the
same people who were annoyed when keith
ellison who converted to islam when he
put you know he swore in on a Koran well
that's his religion thing so if you're
if it's the idea of tradition well then
you should respect other people's
traditions too but they went they went
bonkers over that yeah I mean the best
example of this and the best example of
it I think it's all not the best example
of it playing out in law yeah isn't is a
1983 decision that the Supreme Court
made it Marsh versus chambers Ernie
chambers is great Nebraska state senator
just a firebrand is hoses own row he's
just an amazing guy sued the Nebraska
Legislature for having a chaplain that
gave Christian prayers before every
session quick sidenote we've paid you
and I as US taxpayers have paid 10
million dollars to chaplains for the
House and the Senate to give prayers
every single day before sessions so you
know it's a nice piece of our money
anyway it was particularly odd now
because you know Trump is not religious
in any way like he got the evangelicals
behind him but when you know when he
went to Liberty University and he was
had that just way to yes 2 Corinthians
and he's fumbling and fumbling over the
whole thing and you can see when he goes
to these things these religious related
things he's a businessman he is secular
I believe you may not like his secular
beliefs but it's so it all seems more
all the more ridiculous now well in it
and I mean it goes to
Trump's religion first of all he won 81%
of white evangelicals which is more than
double you more than McCain more than
rummy that I mean that's that's amazing
yeah and it's it shows something of
about I think their willingness to to
elect somebody with these these
authoritarian tendencies I think it's
kind of actually I think it's sort of
the substitution proxy like this is the
God of our Bible is this authoritarian
if you don't love me I'm going to murder
you and you know he payback immediately
and viciously I think this is a little
bit of substitution going on between
that's anyway that's kind of beside the
point we're talking about tradition in
this this case yeah right and the
Supreme Court said that prayers can be
opened at any legislative meeting
because we've been doing it since before
there was a constitution which which it
blows the mind because yeah that so
before there was a separation of state
and church in the Constitution then
before we amended the Constitution with
the First Amendment there were prayers
so we're gonna go ahead and let you
continue to have prayers now it's
nonsense I mean and the dissents in the
case said you know any first-year law
student could look at this and say that
yes having a Christian prayer before a
legislative meeting is an endorsement of
religion and it violates the separation
of state and church and it struck down
but because it's been going on for so
long right that not only does that make
no sense and I'm not a constitutional or
obviously but even if you were to throw
in five other religions and a secular
prayer or a secular statement it would
still be ridiculous yeah so it's not yet
for me at least it wouldn't be just
about the exclusivity of all the other
religions and just giving a Christian
prayer it just makes no sense altogether
agreed agreed completely and you know it
but it is and it always ends up being
exclusively Christian you know from 2000
to 2015
Congress gave 2085 Christian prayers
something like 62 prayers were given by
a Jewish in vacant and then I think
eight Islam and then three others yeah
and that's it so I mean you're talking
ninety-nine point seven percent or
something like that
yeah judeo-christian God's by the way to
be completely fair and show people we're
not picking on Christianity somehow when
the rabbi gave the the speech right at
was it right before Trump took the oath
of office right after which one was a
I don't remember it was that within five
minutes on either side I mean whether
it's a rabbi or Chris I think all of it
yes it has nothing to do with the
government absolutely and it shouldn't
have anything to do with the ghost so
what do you say to people and I've had
people that I said I really like and
admire and respect sit in that very
chair and say to me that you can't fully
separate religion and government because
we're based in judeo-christian values I
get that from Dennis Prager who I really
like and admire yes
I've actually this is the topic of my
book that is hopefully coming out soon
I'm talking with a couple of publishers
the idea so I think first of all you if
you back up the idea that were Christian
nation I think most people most thinking
people can reject that idea some of them
can even refute it but the fallback
position is what you're talking about
well we're founded on judeo-christian
principles and it this is just it's
fundamentally not true first of all
nobody ever tells you what did you do
Christian that is they're they're hiding
in the the vagueness of that term right
and and second of all it is it is just
not true if you look and this is what I
do in my book you look at
judeo-christian principles if you look
at the Ten Commandments each of the Ten
Commandments and break them down if you
look at the principles that are central
to the Bible and break them down and
compare them to America's founding
principles they are in such disagreement
so fundamentally opposed to one of those
that it's fair to say that Christianity
is on America right so for example I
think they would both our Constitution
and the tangka Medes would agree on the
murder thing right we'll give them one
to start we would agree no murder I
would agree no murder okay but believe
in one God that's in the Ten
Commandments I don't think that has
anything to do with our Constitution I
mean actually have the reverse yeah but
the Ten Commandments begin first of all
whenever you whenever you get into an
argument something about the ten
commands you have to ask them which Ten
Commandments are they talking about
there's there's four sets of Ten
Commandments in any given Bible which
Mars are four different four sets Exodus
20 Exodus 34 Deuteronomy 5 and
Deuteronomy 27 really you know one of
those is just a list of people that are
cursed yeah and the first set which is
what everybody thinks of as the Ten
Commandments you know Moses comes down
off the mountain they're not even called
the Ten Commandments in the Bible it's
the second set that is actually called
the Ten Commandments that he has to go
make Moses comes down off the mountain
with the ten commands of the own
we thing the only artifact that God has
ever inscribed and proven his existence
and smashes them because he's angry that
he's pitiful yeah anyway and in the Mel
Brooks movie he had 20 commandments but
them 15 it was a 15 movie was not a
blank that's history the history of the
world yesterday part 1 yeah yeah I mean
leaving aside the Brooks Ian's
recklessness yeah the 10 commandments
the 10 commandments themselves are even
when you get into the the rules like
murder and things like that
those aren't you do Christian these are
universal human principles that every
society we know of has come up with on
their own and to call them
judeo-christian and say that
specifically judeo-christianity
influenced them rather than our innate
humanity I think is arrogant it's the
kind of arrogance that that I am as an
atheist I'm often accused of and
furthermore if you actually look at the
way the Ten Commandments are written and
I'll make this argument in the book the
don't murder don't lie don't steal
Commandments really only applied to
other believers so it's not equal
justice under the law at what we have in
our system it was don't don't kill your
fellow believers otherwise go for it and
if you look at the Bible what does God
do in the books right after the Ten
Commandments he orders them to go
slaughter they commit something like 70
genocides in the Book of Joshua so
killings perfectly fine as long as
you're not telling your your friends
your brothers and your neighbors yeah
you mentioned arrogant and I think that
this is one of the words that gets
prescribed to atheists a lot and I see
this with Bill Maher particularly I
think he's been the most outspoken
American atheist probably that people
while he's just - I like what he says
he's too arrogant he's too whatever in
my defense of him I obviously i really
like in admire him is that you know he's
put himself out on a Ledge here that is
not a popular ledge to be on and he
takes hits now he now he gets more hate
I think from the left but he gets hit
from everybody and he's a little
arrogant about it he's a little smug
about it he is and I don't think he
would deny that and I'll ask him that
one day
but what do you do with that for someone
that that is in your position sure this
idea that atheists are somehow we were
there holier than thou and their smarts
or any that kind of thing
to me it's I don't get that from you by
the way but I think I appreciate that I
mean it to me I think it's kind of
amazing because if you look at the
claims my claim for atheism is I don't
see you having any evidence that it got
exist so I don't believe one yeah I mean
it's it's pretty minimal claim really do
you make it a distinction between that
and agnosticism I don't like going down
the short altars because I sure I do so
atheism is a statement of belief
agnosticism as a statement of knowledge
and there's no way we can ever know a
negative so I'm also an agnostic I'm
also a humanist I'm also a skeptic you
know I have a secularist the delayed the
only label that I choose to give myself
even politically is is atheist and the
reason I that I do that is because you
know I think when we when we label
ourselves
JFK's has a great quote and he says that
too often we enjoy the disc the comfort
of opinion without the discomfort of
thought and I think that labels are just
the quintessential example of that I
don't I don't know what you think about
something but I'm listening to you talk
and then you say oh I'm a conservative
okay I don't have to listen to anything
you say anymore I know I know what your
views are I can ignore the words coming
out of your mouth or I filter those
words through the prism of that label
right so so to me it's you know labeling
something is a way that we can enjoy the
comfort of opinion without the
discomfort of thought so I try to avoid
that but atheism is the exception that I
make to this because I want people to
put me in that atheist box in their
brain and then I'm gonna break out right
like I want them to think that I am this
this arrogant this awful person who's
hates life doesn't you know enjoy their
their family and it's just that
miserable because I'm not I'm a happy
guy I love life I try to get the most
out of it I'm a probably a little bit
arrogant I'm a lawyer you know but it's
really you're a terrible really a
miserable little thing not really
exactly exactly but the point being like
I I that is the one label that I will
adopt for myself even though I am all
those other things and I do it for for
the reasons that I want to I want to
shatter people's misconceptions about
what it is to be an atheist yeah so but
getting back to the whole idea about
atheist being arrogant to me it's a very
simple question like my my statement is
there's no evidence to believe in a God
so I don't the religious point of view
is I have no evidence but complete faith
I have absolute unsick shakable
certainty without any evidence
whatsoever that this is true and to me
that's a far more arrogant believe and
what then what I'm saying
yeah so can those things ever really be
reconciled in a society like let's say
everything you do for the rest of your
career goes exactly how you would want
to write and you're able to maybe bring
some people along and wake some people
up so to speak and all that there's
always going to be religious people and
in many religious people by the way are
perfectly good people who get strapped
to charity of course home lives and do
all sorts of great things and I think
they've done studies where actually
religious people give more money to
things if you include the church the
church is tax-exempt oh we can get into
that too but do you think that in in a
functioning Western democratic society
that those things really can be
reconciled or that we're always gonna
sort of have this battle I think there
will always be religion and I think as
long as you're living in a democratic
republic people are always going to
those who are in government are always
going to try to use their positions in a
certain amount of way to promote their
personal beliefs and when when their
personal beliefs are religion then it
becomes a big problem
you know when their personal beliefs are
based in science it becomes less of an
issue but I think there's always going
to be a conflict between at least at
least an intellectual conflict between
religion and non-religion um I think
religion demographically is in a
tailspin in this country I think it's on
its way out and one of the weird really
weird things about working for a
non-profit you know you said if I'm
completely successful if I'm completely
out of a job I don't know what I'm gonna
do
it's weird this is like the cops need a
certain amount of crime
this is the only good thing about Trump
the only silver lining for me is I have
got job security like there's no problem
for me for four years like that I mean
especially if you look at his cabinet
and his vice president I mean and who
are probably pushing a lot of the policy
I mean it's it's very scary from a state
church standpoint yeah very very scary
time for a guy like you
I suspect you probably fear a Mike Pence
in a way more than you would fear a
Trump sure in a certainly yes in a
certain way absolutely like that Mike
Pence is very scary as is his cat as is
the cabinet I mean Rick Perry is a guy
who when his state had a drought he held
a prayer rally which we sued him over
the state caught fire after his prayer
rally instead of a training Sunday
facing the wrong way they prayed to the
wrong God I don't know sonny perdue you
know Secretary of Agriculture's same
thing his state was going through a
drought he counseled prayer scott pruett
a head of the EPA I've tangled with him
he thinks that it's okay for public
schools to distribute Bibles to students
you know so these these people are very
scary for me I'm curious do you find
that there's a little bit of a point
that you can't reconcile here where you
obviously believe in the Constitution
and our government has gotten much
bigger than the Constitution ever really
wanted I think maybe you disagree that
all of the regulations that the
government is put on are not things that
we're really supposed to happen yet you
don't want them to you know I mean
you're trying to fight things that maybe
aren't constitutional but you want some
regulation to that make did that make
sense I think yeah I think so
and I'm not in other words the
government got much bigger than the
framers intended yes and now you like
some of those regulations because they
do some of this stuff out of the public
square but but really the problem really
is so really it's kind of two questions
really so for my state church work
really all we rely on is is the
Constitution itself and some state
constitution then there are some
peripheral laws that allow us to bring
lawsuits and statutes that allow us to
bring lawsuits and things like that but
really if you look at the original
Constitution without the amendments it
mentions religion once an article six
which is to prohibit religious tests for
public office it's the only mention of
religion is
exclusionary then you have a couple of
amendments again the First Amendment
mentioning religion twice again
excluding government from religion and
vice versa so the only mentions of
religion in the entire Constitution
which is godless doesn't mention God at
all are completely exclusionary so
really the this Center in the core of my
work is based on that I think what
you're talking about more broadly and I
can bring in some of my environmental
background here is you know kind of the
idea of the administrative state right
so that that's where I'm going so I get
in a drawer leaders front so then on
this front where you want as an
environmentalist you want some
regulation no and yet at the same time
that's not exactly what the Constitution
prescribes the federal government to be
able to do sure and it's it is it is I
think different than what the founders
intended but the Constitution is also
different than what the founders passed
you know we have a lot more it's been
amended many times since since the
founders and the administrative state
it's a little weird in mind you know you
take whole classes on this in law school
because there are there are some genuine
simple reasons for having it so Congress
Dianne Feinstein was actually talking
about this earlier in the course such
confirmation hearing she's talking about
what we can set fuel standards for say
the next ten years we're able to we have
that information now but we need experts
at the EPA say to do it for the 15 20 30
years after that we don't have that kind
of scientific expertise so what we're
doing is we're delegating our authority
to the EPA on that and I mean the courts
are pretty good about coming in and
saying when you can and when you can't
do that the whole lot this phone's
Chevron deference that you're hearing
about in the news is is all intertwined
with this so I think I think it's
different than what the founders
intended but I don't think that
necessarily means that that it's
unconstitutional it's certainly becoming
unwieldly
yeah but that also doesn't mean that
it's it's unconstitutional that's that's
a policy issue yeah and I see this as a
very gray area sure I'm not saying that
they're not doing anything that they're
doing something unconstitutional but
just that the power and the reach of the
federal government and the way we the
states have given up so many rights yes
I view that as so you're talking about
federalism yeah so I mean Fedder and
federal
is the the balance of power between the
states and the federal government that's
kind of it it's in it's in the
Constitution it's in the Tenth Amendment
and says that the powers that the
federal government doesn't have are
reserved to the states but again that's
changed a lot over the years especially
with the 13th 14th and 15th amendments
and because the federal government is
spending so much money now which they're
perfectly allowed to do they are allowed
to put strings on that money and that's
one of the ways they're able to do a lot
of these things that you don't hear
about very often
oh isn't that an inherent problem
because it's sort of like a hostage
situation like if you want money for
this you better start doing this and
that may not exactly be what our
jurisdiction says well and but the
courts are willing to strike that down
the Violence Against Women Act was kind
of this famous where where the courts
struck down the Violence Against Women
Act saying it was an overreach of the
Congress under the Commerce Clause they
weren't allowed to do this so I think
courts are willing to defend that but
the power of the purse belongs
exclusively to Congress they are allowed
to spend in whatever way they want and
they can attach they can attach strings
to that money if they want to so it is
it is difficult I see your point
but you have to figure out a different
way around then yeah so for an example
would be like the the trans bathroom law
in North Carolina where Obama started
you know first of all they were trans
people were have been going to the
bathroom for a long time I've never seen
a study saying that it's a problem where
they're going to the bathroom so it
became an issue then of course the media
firestorm about it and then if correct
me if I'm wrong but I think Obama
basically said if you don't allow them
to do this we're gonna was it he was
argue they're gonna cut funding for
certain state things and we saw places
you know the NBA said we're not gonna
have our all-star game there that's a
separate thing from the government of
course but that general idea I didn't
like because I don't want for a basic
non-issue something that I don't think
is a major issue I'm not talking about
trans rights their right to equality but
for that been going to the bathroom or
everything wanted shorts an issue that
then we just we all get hysterical about
it and what's the answer
the federal government should now tell
us what to do and I think I see your
point there yeah but I also think
there's to the idea that that you know
it's not really about bathrooms in the
way that it wasn't you know a lot of
these fights are similar
lunch counters water fountains those
weren't the most pressing problems
facing the civil rights movement but but
they can be powerful symbols when you're
trying to trying to change the way
people view a certain minority and
trying to assert the rights so I think I
think it's important to look at it both
both and we're open to this problem all
the time I mean in in the Freedom From
Religion Foundation what we do you know
we're fighting the symbols constantly
ten commandments on public lands bosses
on publicly and then those are important
fights to have for that very reason so I
think it's not necessarily just about
the bathroom and it's not necessarily
about a non issue kind of in the way
that it's not necessarily about baking a
cake or you know getting giving flowers
to a gay wedding in that that arena
[Music]
you